welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of the
post-credits scenes for Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 spoilers ahead to be honest
during the credits of this film I was
looking up how to adopt every animal and
it turns out you're not supposed to own
ferrets where I live but I got one and
oh God now there are thousands but in
the meantime in the meantime word two
post credit scenes that leave us with
some questions I'm gonna explain
everything you need to know coming out
of these scenes and a lot of details
that you might have missed from them by
the way subscribe to the Deep dive where
Friday May 5th noon Eastern I will do a
live stream breakdown and Q a of the
full volume 3 film and the best way to
support this growing network is to grab
one of our Guardians inspired shirts at
nerd riot.shop like this rocket science
89p13 shirt on the Deep dive collection
okay the film ends with rocket and the
others freeing the test subjects from
the high evolutionary ship and defeating
Herbert Wyndham peeling off his face
Master revealed the bloody mess rocket
head clawed after Windham killed Lila
thieves and floor of batch 89 the
refugees include dozens of children
designed by Windham to have perfect
metabolism kids whom Drax hits it off
with remember drax's wife ovet and his
daughter kamaria were killed by Ronan
the Accuser but in the comics drax's
daughter is a character moon dragon in
Swahili kamaria means like the moon so
we've been wondering how the MCU might
work in moon dragon all these years and
now it seems like they found a way with
mood dragon's partner in the
annihilation Conquest storylines phyla
Vel the artificially engineered daughter
of the original Cree Marvel not Carol
Danvers but her male crazy successor in
the comics phyla is confirmed to be the
name of one of these kids on windham's
ship played by Kaizen and we're going to
talk more about her in a second but
Peter Quill announces he's leaving the
Guardians to go back to Earth to reunite
with his grandfather Jason which is
where Peter got his middle name in the
2014 film mantis also leaves with the
obelisks rocket is named as a new
captain of the Guardians of the Galaxy
Gamora rejoins the ravagers nebula looks
over this nowhere Colony with Drax
serving as the father figure to these
Refugee kids and out of warlock in his
musaki blurp become honorary Guardians
surprisingly none of the key players
actually die in this movie not even the
high evolutionary on screen at least
rocket just kind of leaves him alive on
that floating ship but on to our first
post-credit scene which is the
mid-credit scene it introduces the new
Guardians of the Galaxy lineup which
includes rocket craglin Cosmo Adam
Warlock blurp Groot and Phi Lavelle
who's also suited up in Guardians blue
one of her eyes glows and she now seems
capable of firing energy blast from her
fist it looks as though she's being
established as the character Quasar now
in the comics Anonymous takes the
quantum bands from window Von Quasar and
they are given to fight Lavelle which
enable her to manipulate light energy to
conjure an energy sword and the fact
that her eye glows a specific color just
like how we see Monaco Rambo's eyes glow
colors in one division in the recent
trailer for the Marvels yeah phyla's
Powers here in the MCU seem to be coming
from the same places the powers of Carol
dampers and kamalacan and Monica Rambo
Cree Cosmic radiation like the Bengals
worn by Kamala Khan and the villain of
the upcoming film the Marvel's General
Dar Ben successor to Ronan the Accuser
with her own Cosmic Rod phyla is the
latest character with Cree Bengal Tech
that allows the admission of this kind
of cosmic radiation Bible Quasar could
actually make an appearance in the
Marvels and in case you have noticed the
MCU is definitely setting itself up to
have kid versions of every hero to bring
together a future Young Avengers lineup
so far we have Peter Parker Kamala Khan
Cassie Lane Kate Bishop Riri Williams
America Chavez Hulk's son scar t'challa
Jr Gore's daughter we think her
character's name love heimdall's son
Axel you know that cgi's Spirit face
that they somehow made worse on the
Blu-ray release as well as her good old
friends Tommy and Billy maximoff Billy's
actually rumored to be a teenager in the
upcoming Agatha coven of chaos there was
also a young Loki variant in the tba's
void and Elijah Bradley in the Falcon
the Winter Soldier Marvel could be set
it up in future conflicts where the
adults of the MCU are taken op world or
off reality in an Avengers Secret Wars
conflict leaving it to the kids to
protect Earth in the meantime though
since we won't be getting Avengers
Secret Wars until 2026 or more
realistically later Marvel's got to move
because by then all these young actors
are going to be like on season six of
euphoria but in the scene Groot is
revealed to be the giant boulder that
they were leaning against waking up into
a 25 but tall gargantuan I think this is
Alpha Groot in the I am Groot shorts
baby Groot drew a picture of his larger
form protecting all of them which seemed
like a callback to the 2014 we are group
moment but this baby Groot would have no
memories of his father's life or his
death so instead this might have been
Baby Groot dreaming of his Alpha group
future so why is Groot huge and why does
it keep growing well we talked about
this when he was introduced as his swole
Groot form in the Guardians holiday
special this group is not a clone of his
father he's his father's progeny and
thus has different DNA and a different
anatomical growth rate compared to his
dad the fluoro colossi species grows
from what's called photonic knowledge
it's a photosynthesis type process and
since this group has been exposed to
beans descend from celestials with all
their Celestial light that courses
through their veins this groot's
photonic knowledge might have been
boosted by Celestial light so in the
scene they talk about their favorite
music acts Vila says Britney Spears and
corn craglin says I gotta go with the
man Garth Brooks Cosmo says the
Carpenters haven't had a single bad song
Adam says Adrian bellu both solo and his
work with King Crimson rocket plays from
the Zune redbones come and get your love
which was the first song we heard adult
Peter Quill play in the first Guardians
film as he approached the temple on
Morag to get the orb the Guardians are
protecting a red-skinned race of
humanoid townspoke from a rabid roving
band of creatures Cracklin says I guess
I can handle this by my lonesome if
y'all want to chill referring to the
fact that he's now mastered yondu's yaka
Arrow but Rocket says Nah Nah it'll go
fast if we all do it together and he
wakes up Groot Pila asks don't you feel
a little bad for them because the big
point of this movie was having an
empathy for all of God's creatures or
one of the Gods creatures and Rocket
says yeah sure but these townsfolk can't
protect themselves and Cosmo says on
your word captain and Racket says word
and they all leap into attack I like how
Rockets final word in this movie is word
he's chronologically first word when he
was a child thrown in that batch 89 cage
was hurts now your time with the
Guardians of the Galaxy doesn't have to
end with the conclusion of the film
Trilogy Marvel's Guardians of the Galaxy
is a single player story driven
action-adventure game out now for
PlayStation and Xbox consoles and PC
you've probably heard some great things
about this game it won best narrative at
the game awards 2021 the game features
an all-new story set in an original
Universe these characters are inspired
by both the comic Guardians and the film
Guardians so they feel fresh and
familiar at the same time it's a fun and
epic story but it also has the heart and
deep character arcs that we love about
these films play as Star-Lord and lead a
guardian's team of Drax Gamora Rocket
and Groot there are appearances by
mantis Cosmo and Adam Warlock they all
feel like living breathing characters so
you get to experience something really
unique in being their leader calling the
shots and trying to bring those strong
personalities together there's a great
soundtrack of course with both an epic
orchestral score and some classic 80s
jams they made an original Rock album
just for the game the game includes many
outfits for the Guardians inspired by
the comics and the MCU including suits
inspired by the 2008 Guardians of the
Galaxy Comics just like in volume 3.
continue your guardian's journey with
Marvel's Guardians of the Galaxy on
Playstation Xbox and steam now the
second post credit scene catches up with
Peter and his grandfather Jason in
Missouri Peter eats recurring new
Rockstar sponsor magic spoon cereal and
he wears a shirt for freakies that was a
very sugary and not as good for you 70s
breakfast cereal Grandpa Jason reads
from a newspaper with some headlines
alien abduction Kevin Bacon shares all
referencing Kevin Bacon's abduction by
Drax in the holiday special another
reads Lola the puggle wins Best in Show
at local dog event this weekend Lola is
James Gunn's dog in the first two
Guardians films Glenn came out his
previous dog Dr Wesley Von Spears in
what seems like some retiree Goss Peter
talks about helping a neighbor mower
grass but says she has a 45 year old
adult son who could just watch it from
the porch and should do it instead and
Jason says don't even get me started and
be responsible now I kind of want to
know now well again this seems like just
gossip people in retirement villages
talk about my mind definitely goes
places like Peter's DNA from Meredith
quill and the station quill is what made
Peter uniquely capable of exhibiting ego
Celestial Gene because all of ego's
other kids didn't exhibit the gene so if
Jason had another adult son who lives in
this neighborhood who knows that son
might have an X gene or something thing
the final title card promises the
legendary Star-Lord will return now the
legendary Star-Lord is just how
Star-Lord is known kind of like The
Amazing Spider-Man or the Incredible
Hulk but legendary Star-Lord was also
the name of a 2014 comic run by Sam
Humphries where comic Star-Lord learns
that he is the sister of Victoria AKA
spartax commander of the spartak's royal
guard and daughter of Peter's father in
the comics Emperor Jason or Jason before
we knew that grandpa's name was Jason we
thought it was just a reference to that
in the comics so we'll see in the MCU
Peters have sisters definitely mantis
fellow child of ego who I would say has
a claim to be the new Star-Lord as she
explores the stars with her abilisks but
there may be another child of Jason
quill on Peter's mother's side with a
unique genetic condition to explore this
legendary Star-Lord angle hey big
announcement here if you live in Los
Angeles come join us live for a special
event on Friday May 26th 6 p.m Pacific
at the lyric Hyperion theater there are
limited in-person tickets available and
if you don't live in LA premium live
stream access is available worldwide
links for both the in person and the
live stream tickets are in this video's
description I'd love to hang out with
you also a reminder to subscribe to our
new channel the Deep dive and support us
by grabbing some merch at nerd riot.shop
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
foreign